please welcome back bill Spencer 15
years ago Microsoft launched the
original Xbox with the goal of pushing
console gaming forward we offered an
innovative new new game franchises on a
powerful box with the built-in ability
to connect gamers together and that same
spirit of invention connection and fun
inspires us to this day now we see a
whole new gaming landscape one being
driven by an unprecedented pace of
innovation transformation and creativity
you are leading this shift with the way
you play today while the console
ecosystem is stronger than ever
most of us play games on more than one
device and it's shifting the way we
think about gaming at Xbox we want to
deliver a world where you have more
freedom and choice to play the games you
want with the people you want on the
devices you want a world where you can
play without boundaries a world beyond
generations at Team Xbox we believe you
should have a diverse and expansive
library of games so today we announce
our biggest lineup of games for Xbox one
in Windows 10 along with the Xbox play
anywhere program that enables you to buy
a game once and play it on Xbox one and
Windows 10 we believe in uniting gaming
communities where you can play compete
and connect with friends wherever they
are so today we showed you how Xbox Live
is available for developers to use
across Xbox Windows 10 VR and mobile we
believe in gaming for everyone we're all
gamers our welcome respected and
supported so today we announced new Xbox
Live features to help you build your
network and play your way and we believe
in hardware innovation without
sacrificing compatibility today we
announced the Xbox 1's the new addition
to the X
one family and share that all Xbox one
games and accessories will continue to
work across all members of the Xbox one
family but that's just the beginning we
see exciting opportunities on the
horizon opportunities to unlock new
innovation for both gamers and
developers alike the next step change
for gamers and developers must deliver
true 4k gaming and high fidelity VR so
we've been talking to our friends and
asking them what they want to see from
us I'm really excited to share what
we've been working on
when we think about the future of Xbox
we think about removing barriers for me
and for the fans and for the developers
Xbox has always meant innovation and the
latest technology and delivering the
world's most powerful console is
something we absolutely want to do this
is the console that developers asked us
to build they wanted a console that had
no boundaries had no limitations and
that technology component to us is what
we really need to make our vision and
our art come alive when I saw the specs
of this thing I'm like wow I got true to
like they're really going for it
they're not holding anything back
so we gave the SOC six teraflops of
computing capability to be able to
handle 4k resolutions gamers are going
to get the most powerful graphics
processor that's been put into a game
console today it's gonna make developers
happy it's gonna make gamers happy
because they're gonna get a very
powerful GPU out of it
the highest res the best frame rate no
compromises
you get 4k gaming true 4k resolution I
can't wait to see what developers
actually do with all that horsepower in
the box we can render it's 60 Hertz we
can render fully uncompressed pixels
these are the highest quality pixels
that anybody is seeing and what we're
able to do now is bring that to the
console player my job as a game maker is
about immersion it's about to put you
into an experience than let you live
that experience the richer and more
accurate those visuals are the more
immersive it is and if we can get a lot
more performance and I mean I mean a lot
more like with this we get to much
greater and better game experiences as a
result we're moving fallout4 to VR and
to have a console that can support that
at the resolution and speed that we
really want think it's gonna be magical
this console is a hundred percent for
you guys we read the articles we read
the reviews it's the we heard you
console so that doesn't mean that we're
leaving those and Xbox one behind every
single thing that we've done for Xbox
one will continue the work we add to the
capabilities of the Xbox one in the Xbox
one family without forcing gamers to
abandon all the games in the community
that they love so much these two systems
are part of the same family the games
will work on both the accessories work
on both but the box we're building is
incredible it's gonna have eight CPU
cores over 320 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth
six teraflops of GPU power
it's a monster
project Scorpio will be the next
addition to the Xbox one family and it
is ultimately the next step in
delivering our vision for the future of
gaming beyond generations when it ships
next year we believe it will be the most
powerful console ever built with six
teraflops of power this is Hardware
built specifically to lead the console
industry into true 4k gaming and high
fidelity VR true 4k visuals without
sacrificing quality premiere VR
experiences without sacrificing
performance putting greater graphic
fidelity in the hands of the world's
best creators Xbox one Xbox one s and
Project Scorpio will all be compatible
all Xbox one games and accessories will
play on all three no one gets left
behind
project Scorpio is a serious inflection
point for Team Xbox and we're announcing
project Scorpio today to give our
developers and partners the ability to
take advantage of that capability now in
order to realize their visions for the
future and deliver even more great games
for you today marks the beginning of
gaming beyond generations a future full
of choice a future where we can all play
without boundaries thank you